الع
[Silence]
ان
صلح
ح
السي
[Silence]
اكبر
تكفرنا
اثنتين واحييتنا اثنتين فاعترفنا
فاعترفنا بذنوبنا
فهل الى خروج من سبيل
ذلك بانه
اذا دعي الله وحده كفرتم
وان يشرك به تؤمنوه
فالحكم لله العلي الكبير
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
هو الذي يريكم اياته وينزل لكم من السماء
رزقا
وما يتذكر الا من ينيب
فادعوه مخلصين له فادعوا الله مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره الكافرون
فادعوا الله مخلصين له الدين ولو كره
الكافرون
رفيع الدرجات ذو العرش يلقي الروح من امره
على من يشاء من عباده
على من يشاء
من عباده لينذر يوم التلاق
يومهم بارزون لا يخفى على الله منهم شيء
لمن الملك اليوم
لله الواحد القهار
اليوم تجزى كل نفس بما كسبت لا ظلم اليوم
ان الله سريع الحساب
وانذرهم
يوم الاسفه اذ القلوب لدى الحناجر كاظمين
كاظمين ما للظالمين من حميم ولا شفيع يطاع
يعلم خائنه
الاعين وما تخفي الصدور
الله يقضي بالحق والذين لا والذين
والله يقضي بالحق
والذين يدعون من دونه لا يقضون بشيء
ان الله هو السميع البصير
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
بسم الله
[Silence]
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السلام
আলহামদুলিল্লাহ
ফ্রাইডে comফান
এ সফিকন্সবিলিটির
কফি
অনি
‏some
ofble
take care of
the year
second part of that is significant
expenses as you know that we pay for the
utensils and the services like ‏the
seating and all the expenses that take
that come together so that becomes a
hefty bill so we need to make sure that
we are covered on those two items in
tomorrow and we are going to request
to raise help us raise the funds for
tomorrow for both of those things so I
need to take time to explain to you how
we going to differentiate what you pay
so we going to be raising funds together
‏But when you write the check or you
give us the money you can let us know
where you want to apply for that those
funds. And all you got to do is you can
either just let us know percentage wi
you want 50% for each or you want 70 30
or whatever ra you we can have that
managed insall when you writing the
check in the mo section you can write
that information. ‏So will be able to
ass you if you forg to write it will
still you know you come back and take
fig out what to do to manage that part
of it. So don't not worry about it. Just
we want to in the interest of time we
going to ask for the donations for both
of those causes. ‏So again those the
money tomorrow will be raised for two
things one is the needy of the community
which is very significant
responsibility and can explain to us
inall between and tomorrow and so that's
the second part is the expenses of the
have incurred so both of them with your
help be able to take care of that now be
talking after tomorrow
প 27
[Silence]
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان
لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
الله
ustان
سبحانه وتعالى
هذا هدى
هدى للمتقينر
[Silence]
سبحانه وتعالى
تلك ايات القران وكتاب مبين تلك ايات
القران وكتاب مبين
[Silence]
مبين
UNC
‏that differates
from the disbel
a fundamental differ
in the way that we see the
is that is
that those people of belief ‏The
believer
they see the world through the Quran
they do not see the Quran through the
world this is so important and I think
many of us are thinking to
themselves that you know we already know
this
but the question is do we already know
is
‏gu
upon which youigh all other things
it is the scales that you judge
people by that you judge actions by
that you judge right and wrong by
and one of the biggest problems that we
‏un
though
why happening
becauseitud
in the
you have with the qu in of
being spoken to
‏by
is not that you
and you judge
and if that judg is not to your liking
then you twi it and switch it and move
it and reposition it until it now fits
your narrative
‏here to the people ofeved
and why peopleev
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
البيهقي رحمه الله
etc
inite of all
ممد صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
مهما تتنا به من ايه لتسحرنا بها فما نحن
لك بمؤمنين
priidence
ولما يحيطوا به علما
‏made
to
miracle would have ever sufficed because
they already decided not to believe
whereas a believer look at the musl
today here we sit in a place that could
not be further
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه
‏are
الله سبحانه وتعالى
لا تقدموا بين يدي الله
ورسوله
لا تقدموا
وفي قراءه سبعيه لا تقدموا
سبحانه وتعالى
‏are
gu
if you put you att guide it
will you rather leading you the prop
said in the nar of and listenely to this
naration
thean of
القران
شافع مشفع وماحل مصدق
شافع مشفع يعني يشفع
وشفاعته مقبوله
لدى الله سبحانه وتعالى
وماحل مصدق
يعني خصم
لا يغلب
ان جئت يوم القيامه وخصمك القران فانك
تهلك ولا بد فهو ماحل مصدق
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
رedران
[Silence]
undfe ungران
من جعله بين يديه قاده الى الجنه
قران
ومن جعله وراء ظهره
ساقه الى النار
قران
والعياذ بالله
نور
‏If you try to stand and look into what
does it do to you? It blinds you.
It blinds you.
ر
how
theories
and how could you ever hope to find
guance without the quر
in spite of this we
وكانه يقول بلسان حاله اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله وان عقلي رسول الله
لا اله الا
الله
my
super smart
you don't super smart very clever very
clever got all figured out
this person
this kind of attitude is one of the
leading reasons why we have not raced
the
‏we have moral comp in ours that
very very rough estimate of right and
wrong
but how do we know what is natural and
unnatural
what is perverted and what is not what
is correct and what is incorrect
when we take theران
‏we
don't know about that kinds
this kind way that kind
and conting and doing mental gymnastics
as if the qu we have some scales that
the qu now we going put the quر on
scales and we goingmine what is
‏little to swow we do interetwi
it ity our headand
have even beenar
that have been so misgided
that they have on certain verses of the
quر and
‏I wish
I could
out of the
person is saying something he saying the
quiet part out loud
right
twiing and conting because it just
doesn't sit right you have to be in
order to be by
you have it as
‏I think this
is how
you
what is wrong even if you don't
understand it
you understand this is الله سبحانه وتالى
‏rather have approach
teacher you
speak about
internet and take everyone who has a
right and you hear the mostant
عليه السلام
that
a wife can actually have four husbands
and a man can actually have four wives
they're the same and what's the
difference between a man and a woman
‏and
have
all kind of things where things come
from
assumption
this person not learn from the quر this
person is trying to teach the quر
and this is why we suffine
if you the quر
يا معلم ادم وابراهيم علمني ويا مفهم
سليمان فهمني تقول بلسان حالك
اللهم
الله
understandي
understand nothing you everything
and month of
it would
have one
underst
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يبارك لي ولكم
في القران العظيم اساله تعالى ان ينفعني
واياكم بما فيه من الايات والذكر الحكيم
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
سنه صلاه
our ان شاء الله
[Silence]
ح
استقيموا اعتدلوا استووا
سووا الصف سدوا الخلل
[Arabic recitation]
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعم ت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
اولم يسيروا في الارض فينظروا كيف كان
عاقبه الذين كانوا من قبلهم
كانوا هم اشد منهم قوه واثارا
في الارض فاخذهم الله بذنوبهم
وما كان لهم من الله من واق
ذلك بانهم كانت تاتيهم رسلهم بالبينات
فكفروا
فاخذهم الله انه قوي
انه قوي شديد العقاب
ولقد ارسلنا موسى
باياتنا وسلطان مبين
الى فرعون وهامان وقارون فقالوا ساحر كذاب
فلما جاءهم
بالحق من عندنا
قالوا اقتلوا ابناء الذين امنوا معه
واستحيوا نساءهم
وما كيد الكافرين
الا في ضلال
وقال فرعون ذروني اقتل موسى وليدع ربه اني
اخاف ان يبدل دينكم
او ان يظهر في الارض الفساد
وقال موسى اني عذت بربي وربكم
من كل متكبر لا يؤمن بيوم الحساب
وقال رجل مؤمن من ال فرعون يكتم ايمانه
يكتم ايمانه اتقتلون رجلا
اتقتلون رجلا ان يقول ربي
وقد جاءكم
بالبينات من ربكم
وان يك كاذبا فعليه عليه كذبه وان يك
صادقا يصبكم بعض الذي يعدكم
ان الله لا يهدي من هو مسرف
ان الله لا يهدي من هو مصرف كذاب
يا قوم لكم الملك اليوم ظاهرين في الارض
فمن ينصرنا من باس الله
فمن ينصرنا من باس الله ان جاءنا
قال فرعون ما اريكم الا ما ارى
وما اهديكم الا سبيل الرشاد
وقال الذي امن يا قوم اني اخاف عليكم مثل
يوم الاحزاب
مثل داب قوم نوح وعاد وثمود والذين من
بعدهم
وما الله يريد ظلما للعباد
ويا قوم اني اخاف عليكم يوم التناد
يوم تولون مدبرين ما لكم من الله من عاص
صم ومن يضلل الله فما له من هاد
ولقد جاءكم يوسف من قبل بالبينات
فما زلتم في شك مما جاءكم به حتى
اذا هلك قلتم لن يبعث الله من بعده رسولا
ذلك يضل الله من هو مسرف
مرتاب
الذين يجادلون في ايات الله بغير سلطان
اتاهم
كبر مقتا عند الله
كبر مقتا عند الله وعند الذين امنوا
كذلك يطبع الله على كل قلب متكبر على كل
قلب متكبر جبار
وقال فرعون يا هامان ابن لي صرحا لعلي
ابلغ الاسباب
اسباب السماوات فاطلع الى اله موسى
واني لاظنه
كاذبا
وكذلك زين لفرعون سوء سوء عمله وصد عن
السبيل
وما كيد فرعون الا في تبن
يا قوم اتبعون اهدكم سبيل الرشاد
يا قوم انما
هذه الحياه الدنيا متاع
وان الاخره هي دار القرار
من عمل سيئه
فلا يجزى الا مثلها
ومن عمل صالحا من ذكر او انثى وهو مؤمن
فاولئك
يدخلون الجنه
يرزقون فيها بغير حساب
ويا يا قوم لي ادعوكم الى النجاه وتدعونني
الى النار
تدعونني لاكفر بالله واشرك به ما ليس وما
ليس به علم
ما ليس لي به علم وتد تدعونني لاكفر بالله
واشرك به ما ليس لي به علم وانا ادعوكم
الى العزيز الغفار
لاجر
ما تدعونني اليه ليس له دعوه في الدنيا
ولا في الاخره
وان مردنا الى الله
وان
المسرفين هم اصحاب النار
فستذكرون ما اقول لكم وافوض امري
الى الله
ان الله بصير بالعباد
فوقاه الله سيئات ما مكروه وحاق
بال فرعون سوء العذاب
النار يعرضون عليها غدوا وعشيا
ويوم تقوم الساعه ادخ خلوا ال فرعون اشد
العذاب
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
واذ يتحاجون
في النار فيقول الضعفاء
للذين استكبروا انا كنا
انا كنا لكم تبعا فهل انتم مظنون عما
نصيبا من النار
قال الذين استكبروا انا كل فيها ان الله
قد حكم بين العباد
وقال الذين في النار لخزنه جهنم
ادعوا ربكم يخفف عنا يوما من العذاب
قالوا اولم تك تاتيكم رسلكم بالبينات
قالوا بلى قالوا فادعوا وما دعاء الكافرين
قالوا فادعوا وما دعاء
الكافرين الا في ضلاله
انا لننصر رسلنا والذين امنوا في الحياه
الدن الدنيا
في الحياه الدنيا ويوم يقوم الاشهاد
يوم لا ينفع الظالمين معذرتهم ولهم اللعنه
ولهم اللعنه ولهم سوء الدار
ولقد اتينا موسى الهدى واورثنا بني
اسرائيل الكتاب
هدى وذكر
لاولي الالباب
فاصبر ان وعد الله حق واستغفر لذنبك
واستغفر لذنبك
وسبح بحمد ربك بالعشي والابكار
ان الذين يجادلون في ايات الله بغير سلطان
اتاهم
ان في صدور هم الا كبر ما هم بباريه
فاستعذ بالله انه
هو السميع البصير
لخلق السماوات والارض اكبر من خلق الناس
ولكن
اكثر الناس لا يعلمون
وما يستوي الاعم
والبصير والذين امنوا
والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات ولا المسيء
قليلا
ما تتذكرون
ان الساعه لاتيه لا ريب فيها
ولكن اكثر الناس لا يؤمنون
وقال ربكم ادعون
استجب لكم
وقال ربكم ادعوني استجب لكم ان الذين
يستكبرون عن عبادتي سيدخلون جهنم داخرين
الله الذي جعل لكم الليل لتسكنوا فيه
والنهار مبصرا
ان الله لذو فضل فضل على الناس
ولكن اكثر الناس لا يشكرون
ذلكم الله ربكم خالق كل شيء لا اله الا هو
فانا تؤفكون
كذلك يؤفق الذين كانوا بايات الله يجحدون
الله الذي جعل لكم الارض قرارا والسماء
بناء
وصوركم فاحسن صوركم
ورزقكم
من الطيبات
ذلكم الله ربكم فتبارك الله رب العالمين
هو الحي لا اله الا هو فادعوه مخلصين له
ين
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
قل اني نهت ان اعبد الذين تدعون من دون
الله لما جاءني البينات من ربي
وامرت ان اسلم لرب العالمين
هو الذي خلقكم من تراب ثم من نطفه ثم من
نطفه ثم من علقه ثم يخرجكم طفلا
ثم لتبلغوا اشدكم
ثم لتكونوا شيوخا
ومنكم
من يتوفى من قبل ولتبلغوا اجلا مسما
ولعلكم تعقلون
هو الذي يحيي ويميت فاذا قضى امرا فانما
يقول له كن فيكون
الم تر الى الذين يجادلون في ايات الله
انا يصرفون
الذين كذبوا بالكتاب وبما ارسلنا به رسلنا
فسوف يعلمون
اذ الاغلال في اعناقهم والسلاسل يسحبون
يسحبون في الحميم
ثم في النار يسجرون
ثم قيل لهم اينما كنتم تشركون
من دون الله قالوا ضلوا عنا
بل لم نكن ندعو من قبل شيئا
كذلك يضل الله الكافرين
ذلكم بما كنتم تفرحون في الارض بغير الحق
وبما كنتم تمرحون
ادخل ادخلوا ابواب جهنم خالدين فيها
فبئس مثوى المتكبرين
فاصبر ان وعد الله حق
فاما نرينك بعض الذين عدهم او نتوفينك
فالينا يرجعون
ولقد ارسلنا رسلا من قبلك منهم من قصصنا
عليك ومنهم ومنهم من لم نقصص عليك
وما كان لرسول ان ياتي بايه الا باذن الله
فاذا جاء امر الله قضي بالحق وخسر هنالك
المبطلون
الله الذي جعل لكم الانعام لتركبوا منها
لتركبوا منها ومنها تاكلون
ولكم فيها منافع ولتبلغوا عليها حاجه في
صدوركم
وعليها وعلى الفلك تحملون
ويريكم اياته فاي ايات الله تنكرون
افلم يسيروا في الارض فينظر انظروا كيف
كان عاقبه الذين من قبلهم
كانوا اكثر منهم واشد قوه واثارا
في الارض فما اغنى عنهم
فما اغنى عنهم ما كانوا يكسبون
فلما جاءتهم
رسلهم بالبينات
فرحوا بما عندهم
فرحوا بما عندهم من العلم وحاق بهم ما
كانوا به يستهزئون
فلما راوا باسنا قالوا قالوا امنا بالله
وحده وكفرنا بما كنا به مشركين
فلم يك ينفعهم ايمانهم لما راوا باسنا
سنه الله التي قد خلت في عباده
وخسر هنالك الكافرون
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
تنزيل
من الرحمن الرحيم
كتاب فصلت اياته قرانا عربيا لقوم يعلمون
بشيرا ونذيرا
فاعرض اكثرهم فهم لا يسمعون
وقالوا قلوبنا في اكنه
مما ما تدعونا اليه وفي اذاننا وقر ومن
بيننا وبينك حجاب
فاعمل اننا عاملون
قل انما انا بشر مثلكم يوحى الي
يوحى الي انما الهكم اله واحد فاستقيموا
اليه واستغفروه
وويل للمشركين
الذين لا يؤتون الزكاه وهم بالاخره هم
كافرون
ان الذين لا يؤتون الزكاه وهم بالاخره هم
ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لهم اجر
غير ممنون
قل اانكم لتكفرون بالذي خلق الارض في
يومين وتجعلون له اندادا
ذلك رب العالمين
وجعل فيها رواسي من فوقها وبارك فيها وقدر
فيها اقواتها في اربعه ايام في اربعه ايام
سواء للسائلين
ثم استوى الى السماء وهي دخان فقال لها
فقال لها وللارض ائتيا طوعا او كرها
قال اتينا طائعين
فقضاهن سبع سماوات
في يومين
واوحى
واوحى في كل سماء امرها
وزينا السماء الدنيا بمصابيح وحفظا
ذلك تقدير العزيز العليم
فان اعرضوا فقل انذرتكم
صاعقه مثل صاعقه عاد وثمود
اذ جاءتهم
الرسل من بين ايديهم ومن خلفهم الا تعبدوا
الا تعبدوا الا الله
قالوا لو شاء الله لانزل ملائكه
فانا بما ارسلتم به كافر كافرون
فاما عاد فاستكبروا في الارض بغير غير
الحق وقالوا
وقالوا من اشد منا قوه اولم يروا ان الله
الذي خلقهم هو اشد منهم قوه وكانوا
باياتنا يجحدون
فارسلنا عليهم ريحا صرصرا في ايام نحسات
لنذيقهم
لنذيقهم عذاب الخزي في الحياه الدنيا
ولعذاب الاخره اخزى وهم لا ينصرون
واما
ثمود فهديناهم فاستحبوا نا على الهدى
فاخذتهم صاعقه العذاب الهون بما كانوا
يكسبون
ونجينا الذين امنوا وكانوا يتقون
ويوم يحشر اعداء
الله الى النار فهم يوزعون
حتى اذا ما جاؤوها شهد عليهم سمعهم
وابصارهم وجلودهم
وجلودهم
بما كانوا يعملون
وقالوا لجنودهم لم شهدتم علينا
قالوا انطقنا الله الذي انطق كل شيء
وهو خلقكم اول مره واليه ترجعون
وما كنتم تستترون ان يشهد عليكم
ان يشهد عليكم سمعكم ولا ابصاركم وج وما
كنتم تستترون ان يشهد عليكم سمعكم
وابصاركم وجنودكم
وما كنتم تستترون ان يشهد عليكم سمعكم ولا
ابصاركم ولا جلودكم
ولكنكم ظننتم ان الله لا يعلم كثيرا مما
تعملون
وذلكم ظنكم
الذي ظننتم
بربكم ارداكم
ارداكم فاصبحتم
من الخاسرين
فان يصبروا فالنار مثوا لهم
وان يستعتبوا فما هم من المعتدين
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
والله مو عارف
سبحان الله بس مو
[Silence]
شيخ ياخلي
الشيخ يصلي بكره
بيقول هنعمل ميتن بعد
تعبان بكره ولا ايه؟ والله حرام
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
عمل صالحا نفسه ومن
علينا
[Silence]
وجعل
وضحقناهم
[Silence]
رحمه اللهم
صل
الذين كفر
على
[Silence]
سمعنا اللهم
كان
[Silence]
السماوات
‏low you low setting
‏I always get hot guys.
[Silence]
يلا
استووا اعتدلوا استووا
سجده التلاوه
ركعه ان شاء الله سجده سجده تلاوه ركعه
عشان هيك
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم رحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
وقيضنا لهم قرناء
فزينوا لهم ما بين ايديهم وما خلفهم
وحق عليهم القول في امم قد خلت من قبلهم
من الجن والانس انهم كانوا خاسرين
قال الذين كفروا لا تسمعوا لهذا القران
والغوا فيه لعلكم تغلبون
فلنذيقن الذين كفروا عذابا شديدا
ولنجزينهم
اسوا الذي كانوا يعملون
ذلك جزاء
اعداء
الله النار
لهم فيها دار الخلد جزاء
بما كانوا باياتنا يجحدون
وقال الذين كفروا ربنا وقال الذين كفروا
ربنا ارنا الذين اضلانا من الجن والانس
نجعلهما تحت اقدامنا ليكونا من الاسفلين
ان الذين قالوا ربنا ثم استقاموا تتنزل
عليهم الملائكه
الا تخافوا ولا تحزنوا
وابشروا بالجنه التي كنتم توعدون
نحن اولياؤكم
في الحياه الدنيا وفي الاخره ولكم فيها ما
تشتهي انفسكم ولكم فيها ما تدعون
نزلا من غفور رحيم
ومن احسن قولا ممن دعا الى الله وعمل
صالحا وقال انني من المسلمين
ولا تستوي الحسنه ولا السيئه ادفع بالتي
هي احسن فاذا الذي بينك وبينه عداوه
كانه ولي حميم
وما يلقاها الا الذين صبروا وما يلقاها
الا ذو حظ عظيم عظيم
واما ينزغنك
من الشيطان نزغ فاستعذ بالله
انه هو السميع العليم
ومن اياته الليل والنهار والشمس والقمر لا
تسجدوا للشمس ولا للقمر واسجدوا لله الذي
خلقهن
ان كنتم اياه تعبدون
فان استكبروا فالذين عند ربك يسبحون له
بالليل والنهار
يسبحون له بالليل والنهار وهم لا يسامون
الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
ومن اياته انك ترى الارض خاشعه فاذا
انزلنا عليها الماء اهتزت وربت ان الذي
احياها لمحيي الموتى انه على كل شيء قدير
ان الذين يلحدون في اياتنا لا يخفون علينا
افمن يلقى في النار خير امن ياتي امنا يوم
القيامه
اعملوا ما شئتم انه بما تعملون بصير
ان الذين كفروا بالذكر لما جاءهم
وانه لكتاب عزيز
لا ياتيه الباطل من بين يديه ولا من خلفه
تنزيل
من حكيم حميد
ما يقال لك الا ما قد قيل للرسل من قبلك
ان ربك لذو مغفره وذو عقاب اليم
ولو جعلناه قرانا اعجميا لقالوا لولا فصلت
اياته
اعجمي وعربي
قل هو للذين امنوا هدى وشفاء
والذين لا يؤمنون في اذانهم وقر وهو عليهم
عماى اولئك ينادون من مكان بعيد
ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب فاختلف فيه ولولا
كلمه سبقت من ربك لقضي بينهم وانهم لفي شك
منه مريب
من عمل صالحا فلنفسه ومن اساء
فعليها
وما ربك بظلام للعبيد
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
من عمل صالحا فلنفسه
ومن اساء
فعليها وما ربك بظلام للعبيد
اليه يرد علم الساعه وما تخرج من ثمرات من
اكمامها وما تحمل من انثى ولا تضع الا
بعلمه
ويوم يناديهم اين شركائي
قالوا اذنا كما منا من شهيد
وضل عنهم ما كانوا يدعون من قبل وظنوا ما
لهم من محيص
لا يسام الانسان من دعاء
الخير وان مسه الشر فيؤوث قنوط
ولئن اذقناه رحمه منا من بعد ضراء امسته
ليقولن هذا ليقولن
ذلك لي وما اظن الساعه قائمه
ولئن رجعت الى ربي ان لي عنده للحسنى
فلننبئ
الذين كفروا بما عملوا ولنذيقنهم
من عذاب غليظ
واذا انعمنا على الانسان اعرض وناى بجانبه
واذا مسه الشر فذو دعاء
عريض
قل ارايتم ان كان من عند الله ثم كفرتم به
من اضل ممن هو في شقاق بعيد
سنريهم اياتنا في الافاق وفي انفسهم حتى
يتبين لهم انه الحق اولم يكف بربك انه على
كل شيء شهيد
الا انهم في مريه من لقاء ربهم الا انه
بكل شيء محيط
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ح م
ع
س
قاف
كذلك يوحي اليك والى الذين من قبلك الله
العزيز الحكيم
له ما في السماوات وما في الارض وهو العلي
العظيم
تكاد السماوات يتفطرن من فوقهن والملائكه
يسبحون بحمد ربهم
والملائكه
يسبحون بحمد ربهم ويستغفرون لمن في الارض
الا ان الله هو الغفور الرحيم
والذين اتخذوا من دونه اولياء
الله حفيظ عليهم وما انت عليهم بوكيل
وكذلك اوحينا اليك قرانا عربيا لتنذر ام
القرى ومن حولها وتن انذر يوم الجمع لا
ريب فيه
فريق في الجنه وفريق في السعير
ولو شاء الله لجعلهم امه واحده ولكن يدخل
من يشاء في رحمته
والظالمون ما لهم من ولي ولا نصير
ام اتخذوا من دونه اولياء
فالله هو الولي وهو يحيي الموتى وهو على
كل شيء قدير
وما اختلفتم فيه من شيء فحكمه الى الله
ذلكم الله ربي عليه توكلت واليه انيب
فاطر السماوات والارض جعل لكم من انفس
انفسكم ازواجا ومن الانعام ازواجا يذراكم
فيه
ليس كمثله شيء وهو السميع البصير
له مقاليد السماوات والارض يبسط الرزق لمن
يشاء
ويقدر
انه بكل شيء عليم
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعم انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
شرع لكم من الدين ما وصى به نوحا والذي
اوحينا اليك وما وصينا به ابراهيم وموسى
وعيسى
ان اقيموا الدين ولا تتفرقوا فيه كبر على
المشركين ما تدعوهم اليه
الله يجتبي اليه من يشاء ويهدي اليه من
ينيب
وما تفرقوا الا من بعد ما جاءهم العلم
بغيا بينهم ولولا كلمه سبقت من ربك الى
اجل مسم لقضي بينهم وان الذين اورثوا
الكتاب من بعدهم لفي شك منه مريب
فلذلك فادع واستقم كما امرت فلذلك فادع
واستقم كما امرت ولا تتبع اهواء واءهم
وقل امنت بما انزل الله من كتاب
وامرت لاعدل بينكم وامرت لاعدل بينكم الله
ربنا وربكم لنا اعمالنا ولكم اعمالكم لا
حجه بيننا وبينكم الله يجمع بيننا واليه
المصير ير
والذين يحاجون
في الله من بعد ما استجيب له حجتهم داحظه
عند ربهم وعليهم غضب ولهم عذاب شديد
الله الذي انزل الكتاب بالحق والميزان
وما يدريك لعل ساعه قريب
يستعجل بها الذين لا يؤمنون بها والذين
امنوا مشفقون منها ويعلمون انها الحق الا
ان الذين يمارون في الساعه لفي ضلال بعيد
الله لطيف بعباده يرزق من يشاء
وهو القوي العزيز
من كان يريد حرث الاخره نزد له في حرثه
ومن كان يريد حرث الدنيا نؤته منها وما له
في الاخره من نصيب
ام لهم شركاء شرعوا لهم من الدين ما لم
ياذن به الله
ولولا كلمه الفصل لقضي بينهم وان الظالمين
لهم عذاب اليم
ترى الظالمين مشفقين مما كسبوا وهو واقع
بهم
والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات في روضات
الجنات لهم ما يشاءون
عند ربهم ذلك هو الفضل الفضل الكبير
ذلك الذي يبشر الله عباده الذين امنوا
وعملوا الصالحات
قل لا اسالكم عليه اجرا الا الموده في
القربى ومن يقترف حسنه نزد له فيها حسنا
ان الله غفور شكور
ام يقولون افترى على الله كذبا ان يشا
يختم على قلبك ويمحو الله الباطل ويحق
الحق بكلماته
انه عليم بذات الصدور
وهو الذي يقبل التوبه عن عباده ويعفو عن
السيئات ويعلم ما تفعلون
ويستجيب الذين امنوا
ويستجيب الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
ويزيدهم
من فضله والكافرون لهم عذاب شديد
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ولو بسط الله الرزق لعباده لبغوا في الارض
ولكن ينزل بقدر ما يشاء
انه بعباده خبير بصير
وهو الذي ينزل الغيب ث من بعد ما قنطوا
وينشر رحمته وهو الولي الحميد
وهو الذي ينزل الغيث من بعد ما قنطوا
ومن اياته خلق السماوات والارض وما بث
فيهما من دابه
وهو على جمعهم اذا يشاء قدير
وهو على جمعهم اذا يشاء قدير وما اصابكم
من مصيبه فبما كسبت ايديكم ويعفوا عن كثير
وما انتم بمعجزين في الارض وما لكم من دون
الله من ولي ولا نصير
ومن اياته الجوار في البحر كالاعلام
ان يشا يسكن الريح فيظللن رواكد على ظهره
ان في ذلك لايات لكل صبار شكور او يوبقهن
بما كسبوا ويعف عن كثير
ويعلم الذين يجادلون في اياتنا ما لهم من
محيص
فما اوتيتم من شيء فمتاع الحياه الدنيا
وما عند الله خير وابقى للذين امنوا وعلى
ربهم يتوكلون
والذين يجتنبون كبائر
الاثم والفواحش واذا ما غضبوا هم يغفرون
والذين استجابوا لربهم واقاموا الصلاه
وامرهم شوراى بينهم ومما رزقناهم هم
ينفقون
والذين اذا اصابهم البغي هم ينتصرون
وجزاء سيئه سيئه مثلها فمن عفى واصلح
على الله انه لا يحب الظالمين
انه لا يحب الظالمين
ولما ولما فمن انتصر بعد ظلمه فاولئك ما
عليهم من سبيل انما السبيل على الذين
يظلمون الناس ويبغون في الارض بغير الحق
اولئك
لهم عذاب اليم
ولمن صبر وغفر ان ذلك لمن عزم الامور
ومن يضلل الله فما له من ولي من بعده وترى
الظالمون لما راوا العذاب يقولون هل الى
مرد من سبيل
وظ
[Arabic recitation]
الى مرد من سبيل
وتراهم يعرضون عليها خاشعين من الذل
ينظرون من طرف خفي
وقال الذين امنوا ان الخاسرين الذين خسروا
انفسهم واهليهم يوم القيامه الا ان
الظالمين في عذاب مقيم
وما كان لهم من اولياء
ينصرونهم
من دون الله
ومن يضلل الله فما له من سبيل
استج جيبوا لربكم من قبل ان ياتي يوم لا
مرد له من الله
ما لكم من ملجا يومئذ وما لكم من نكير
فان اعرضوا فما ارسلناك عليهم حفيظا ان
عليك الا البلاغ
وانا اذا انعم وانا اذا اذقنا الانسان منا
رحمه فرح بها وان تصبهم سيئه بما قدمت
ايديهم فان الانسان كفور
لله ملك السماوات والارض يخلق ما يشاء
يهب لمن يشاء اناثا ويهب لمن يشاء الذكور
او يزوجهم ذكرانا واناثا ويجعل من يشاء
عقيما
انه عليم قدير
وما كان لبشر ان يكلمه الله الا وحيا او
من وراء حجاب
او من وراء حجاب او يرسل رسولا فيوحي
باذنه ما يشاء
انه علي حكيم
وكذلك اوحينا اليك روحا من امرنا ما كنت
تدري ما الكتاب ولا الايمان
ولكن جعلناه نورا نهدي به من نشاء من
عبادنا
وانك لتهدي الى صراط مستقيم
صراط الله الذي له ما في السماوات وما في
الارض الا الى الله تصير الامور
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
عربي
الله
اكبر
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
اذا جاء
نصر الله والفتح
ورايت الناس يدخلون في دين الله افواجا
فسبح بحمد ربك واستغفره
انه كان توابا
الله
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
تبت يدا
ابي لهب وتب
ما
اغنى عنه ماله وما كسب سيصلى نارا
ذات لهب وامراته
حماله
الحطب في جيدها حبل بل من مسد الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبرصلوات
والطيبات السلام
عليكم
وبركاته والسلام
اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد صليت على
ابراهيم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
قل هو الله احد
الله الصمد
لم يلد ولم يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
انه لا يذ
واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا من جا منك الا اليك
اللهم اننا عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو
امائك نواصينا في يدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل
فينا قضاؤك نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به
نفسك او انزلته
في كتابك او علمته احدا من خلقك او
استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك
ان تجعل القران ربيع قلوبنا
ونور صدورنا
وجلاء
احزاننا
وذهاب همومنا
علمنا منه ما جاهلناه
وذكر وذكرنا منه ما انسينا
اللهم اجعله شافعا مشفعا لنا ولا تجعله
حجه علينا
اللهم املا به صدورنا
وقلوبنا
وابصارنا
واسماعنا
ولحوم
نا وعظامنا
ودمائنا
اللهم رطب به السنتنا
اللهم اجعله لنا نورا في الدنيا هدى وعلى
الصراط دليلا
وفي الاخره نورا
اللهم اننا نعوذ بك من جهد البلاء
ودرك الشقاء
وسوء القضاء
وشماته الاعداء
اللهم اننا نسالك عيش السعداء
ومنازل الشهداء
ومرافقه
الانبياء
والنصر على الاعداء
يا سميع الدعاء
يا ذا المن والعطاء
يا ذا الطول والكرم والجود والعطاء
اللهم اننا نسالك موجبات رحمتك وعزائم
مغفرتك والغنيمه من كل بر والسلامه من كل
اثم والفوز بالجنه
والفوز بالجنه
والنجاه من النار
اللهم اننا نسالك فعل الخيرات
وترك المنكرات
وحب المساكين
وان تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا
واذا اردت بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير
مفتونين
ربنا
احينا ما كانت الحياه خيرا لنا وتوفنا
اذا كانت الوفاه خيرا لنا اللهم انصر
الاسلام والمسلمين
واخذل الشرك والمشركين
وافضح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم انصر عبادك المجاهدين
في غزه وفلسطين
وفي السودان وفي كشمير
وحيث حلوا اجعلهم منصورين
على عدوهم ظاهرين
ربنا احفظ المسجد الاقصى من عبث العابثين
وصبر اهله يا رب العالمين
اللهم عليك بهذا الكيان الصهيون اللعين
عدوك وعدو الدين
اللهم دمره تدمير
اللهم اننا نعوذ بك من شرورهم
ونجعلك في نحورهم
اللهم اجعل تدبيرهم تدميرهم
وصدع بنيانهم
وزلزل اركانهم
واقتل اجنادهم
واقذف في قلوبهم الفزع والرعب والهلع
واضرب عليهم الذل والهوان
واجعل قتلاهم في النيران
واجعل احياءهم
في ذل وهوان
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس
سبحان
الملك القدوس
[Silence]
حيا
ان شاء
‏How much
think some things
and
how are you? علكم السلام